let's see who else is holding on today
what about maybe the 2:8 one area code
caller from two eight one introduce
yourself tell us who you are where
you're calling from and what's on your
mind today
hey David this is Rob I live in the
Philadelphia area I just wanted to ask
you do you can you attribute the record
low unemployment rate to Trump's tax
cuts tax cuts no I can't I mean Kenny
can you how would that work or it I
guess in in what ways would would the to
be related well I mean I don't think it
has anything to do with with the tax
cuts but I debate Republican probably
every day on this and I just wanted to
see if there's any way that I could
point out that you know there's no
there's no correlation to to the record
low unemployment well there's been a
correlation in a sense that the tax cuts
happened and then we've got record low
unemployment I mean I think I would
focus on two things first I would ask
them whether they they trusted those
same unemployment numbers under Obama
right because right off the bat there's
a huge hypocrisy and that the people
cheering those numbers said that they
were fake under Obama so that's number
one
but I would just ask really specifically
how did the tax a plan we can't even
call it a tax cut I mean it was a cut
for some people how did the tax reform
lead to lower unemployment and really
press them for specifics what exactly
about the change in the tax law caused
companies to advertise and hire people
for more jobs and I think you'll see it
pretty pretty quickly falls apart yeah
yeah well thank you Grantham for the
question all right no problem whatsoever
thank you for calling